my Scouts have reported back from the
lands to the north
the situation is far worse than I ever
imagined The Cult of kathon is on our
doorstep and in great numbers worse
still they've been capturing Farmers
Travelers even my own soldiers and using
them for their blood rituals we cannot
risk the cult bolstering their forces
with cathonic beings I need you to
venture out Beyond Sorrows Bastion to
the north and search their camps rescue
any survivors before the cultists can
use them as sacrifices
foreign
just the person I'm looking for The
Others May disagree with me on this
there are two other groups of survivors
in the region that we are aware of but
Somer and Creed do not consider them to
be of strategic value frankly I disagree
they may consist largely of fanatics but
Fanatics aimed in the right direction
can be a powerful force I've asked
representatives from both the order of
deaths vigil and kaiman's chosen to
visit here and speak to us there is some
obvious animosity between the two but
perhaps we can leverage that against
them I would like you to be our
representative speak to both of them
learn all that you can and decide which
of the two groups would prove to be of